Hey guys, this is Houston with the Great
Race. I've got the pleasure to be here
in beautiful Auburn, Indiana with the X
Cup Legacy this weekend. We're out
shooting some training videos with my
good friends here. So, my name's Glynn
Douglas. I've been a X Cup participant
for 2 years in a row now. Today, I'm
going to talk to you about acceleration
deceleration performance charts, stop
and start charts, and then turn charts.
I'm Nigel Strat. I'm the prior owner of
this 1957 Plymouth two-door station
wagon. So, most important thing to get
these charts down correctly is you have
to have your time-wise speedometer. You
have to have your good working
stopwatch. You also have your driver
navigator pair set up and ready to go.
And so, to do these measurements, you
have to have a stretch of road that is
straight and it's safe that you can
legally get up from 0 to 55 mph.
Preferably, go back at again at 55 mph
to get your measurements done as quickly
and efficiently as possible. The best
way to fill this out is using the charts
creation tool you can get directly from
Great Race. The absolute best way to get
the best measurements possible is to
fill it out live while you are doing the
measurements in person. So, the first of
these charts that you're going to make
will be with two cones, two checkpoints.
You're going to enter the first
checkpoint going your desired speed.
You'll maintain that speed and exit the
second checkpoint at that same speed.
The second chart you will make will be
from a dead stop at the first checkpoint
to then accelerate to your desired speed
and maintain that speed to your second
checkpoint where you will end. Your
third and final chart is arguably the
most difficult. You will enter the first
checkpoint at your desired speed. You
will then brake until your front bumper
is touching the second checkpoint. This
may take multiple tries and be very
difficult, but this is arguably one of
your most important measurements to
make. For our demonstration today, we'll
be using two different telephone poles
as our checkpoint. We have one close to
us and one farther away from us on the
straight road of ours. This is how we
will measure ourselves throughout our
course today. So, now join us in the
cars we walk you through each of these
different measurements.
So, now our measurement is going to be
made by starting at that pole of 25
miles an hour. So, before the pole,
we're going to accelerate to 25. We're
going to maintain that speed up and
through and through that second pole.
Then, I will show you our measurements
at that point. Okay, Nigel? Here we go.
And so, for a second charting, we're
going to be doing this one from a stop
to the other pole. So, in this
situation, Nigel's pulled up the car to
his front bumper in line with our first
checkpoint. We're starting from a dead
zero. We will get up to 25 miles an
hour, maintain that speed, then I will
hit the stopwatch again once we cross
our second checkpoint. So, now, Nigel,
you're ready?
All right.
>> And so let's start our final charting.
We're going to enter into our first
checkpoint at 25 miles an hour. We will
break as soon as we hit the first
checkpoint and Nigel's goal is to have a
consistent deceleration braking the
entire way to the second checkpoint.
Hopefully you will finish with this
front bumper on the second checkpoint.
So Nigel, you ready? Yep. All right.
>> So today you saw us go through and make
measurements for each of our three
charts, but each time we did it, we only
did it at 25 miles an hour. In reality,
you need to do it at every speed four
times to get an average. You need to do
that again for every driver that you
have. Realistically, you need to set
aside about four hours to do these tests
properly and it's going to burn gas and
it's going to burn time, but it's worth
it. This is truly the most efficient way
to have your time down for the X-Cup.
So, this is your chart creation tool you
will get directly from Gray Race. What
we just did out there was our
measurements for these each of these
three different charts.
So,
first we did was at a constant speed. We
only did one run of this, which would be
a 25 mph constant speed, which is
roughly 19 seconds we had.
Then, we didn't do four runs like you're
supposed to do, which is how you get the
most um direct time. Once you set this
in, you see how it already changes it to
an average. Just put all your times in
there, all your speeds, you'll get a new
average each time you input it. Again,
about 18 second average on that.
Again, 25 mph, we had 17.
So, to fill out this form,
there is a yellow highlighted area on
the right side of the screen over here,
here, and here. It will tell you how to
do everything you need to do, give you
your averages, do the math for you, then
output it as your performance chart.
Make sure you convert the seconds for
your inputs though. It is very
important. If you input it as a 1 minute
and 2 second time, it will not take it
and it will not convert it for you. It
has to be in seconds.
But, now you have your chart, you have
your calculations, and this will give it
to you. And so, now a common problem you
can have while using this Gray Race
chart is to find a negative number in
your average charts. So, looking at our
acceleration braking, have a negative
2.7. Obviously, that's not possible. You
can't have a negative number.
So, going back into our to our constant
speed chart, looking at our 25 column,
we have a 19.8, 19.9, 19.1, and 19.8
again.
Obviously, our 19.1 is the outlier.
Seeing that this is our problem, you can
either simply delete it and leave it off
your averages, or you can go out again,
rerun the score, report back with your
score, create a new average, and that's
what we recommend to be the most
accurate thing for you to use in your
charts. Uh that's excellent. Well, thank
you so much for all this information. We
appreciate you guys tuning in and being
here with us today with our good friends
from X-Cup X-Cup Legacy and we got our
good friend Nigel here with our great
donation car behind us.